había sido calificado en su momento como
el contrato del siglo y su ruptura
repentina supone un nuevo golpe para
francia que hace apenas tres meses ya
había perdido un contrato para vender
aviones rafael a suiza que prefirió los
f-35 estadounidenses el ministro francés
de exteriores denunció el acuerdo hocus
con el que eeuu y reino unido- proveerán
australia con nueva tecnología en busca
de limitar el auge de china en el lindo
pacífico sin remo buffon se acude
realmente es una puñalada por la espalda
construimos una relación de confianza
con australia que fue traicionada
esto no se hace entre aliados esta
decisión abrupta e impredecible se
parece mucho de lo que hacía don al
traje invisible sabes son buques fusión
el acuerdo de 40.000 millones de dólares
con la empresa estatal francesa naval
group fue alcanzado en 2016 durante el
gobierno de françois hollande ya había
sido reconfirmado hace tan sólo dos
semanas
éste preveía fabricar 12 submarinos para
australia una flota que ahora será
construida por eeuu con tecnología de
propulsión nuclear por su parte la unión
europea dijo no haber sido informada del
acuerdo e insistió nuevamente en
fortalecer su independencia militar o de
sitio un buen ocasión el papel es una
buena oportunidad para recordar para
reflexionar sobre la necesidad de
plantear la cuestión de la autonomía
estratégica europea de gic que
entretanto china rechazó la alianza que
tachó de irresponsable realidad
la cooperación de eeuu reino unido y
australia en submarinos nucleares daña
gravemente la paz y la estabilidad
regional e intensifica la carrera
armamentística y pone en peligro los
esfuerzos regionales para promover la no
proliferación de armas nucleares
a todo esto australia dijo que había
tomado su decisión pensando en la mejor
forma de proteger sus intereses por su
parte de eeuu defendió el pacto y
rechazó las críticas de china y francia
a la vez que aclaró no estar buscando
conflicto con beijing